hi I'm Greg e I'm Johnny we're going to
do a video today requested from a lot of
lot of a lot of people first person
requests is mad Titan 7800 for an evil
in of Clash of the Titans mad Titan 78
specific witty shout out just for you my
friend I write this material myself John
are you ready to get your blonde on I
can't wait to get my blonde on jaynewick
let's do Dane wick I choose this Sunday
don't get me killed today
[Music]
yeah thanks for the intelligence
collection and hands come on don't get
one who's killed were snacks
[Music]
did you know enough to sailing yes sex
here telling you our modulation and find
out who's hunting Robert and Trust know
[Music]
again focus apartment hunting oh yeah
mighty touch the ground egg pasta plan
it's part of my a block without
prompting who's been following me he
looks like any favor
[Applause]
hi so you made contact with the French
opera
[Music]
[Music]
the clock is ticking for everyone you do
close to ends up dead why they share
that
[Music]
[Applause]
my god I think I love you
[Music]
James McAvoy's on the titles now yeah
come in like halfway through the video
oh boy that looks cool as hell I love it
I would love it awesome you know like
when we saw the first trailer
everyone compared to fighting south of
John wick and while and of course or you
know the similarities are still present
it's still a little different though I
mean yeah looks more like James like a
James Bond like the look on Ross like
John Wayne yeah but it looks more like a
James Bond type of mood yeah world
because she's doing more hand-in-hand
combat than she is doing gunplay it's
always primarily unemployed she's doing
a lot of hand in hands here when I get
the sense that she's just an assassin
either you know like I don't know I know
exactly what she's up to
I'm sexualized sexual assassin so you
know I'm just not bisexual ah no but he
did get that one got it scratches balls
this lips does not stop I've heard that
the comic book is not as cool with this
I mean I'm not happy to say it like
punched it up considerably because this
just looks bone-crushing I mean this
just looks like one crazy ass fight
after the next but obviously you know
when it comes to one of the directors of
John wake you're expecting to be shot
really cool and it's totally living up
to that but the style of it you know the
British the British world here's
something I'm really drawn to hear the
kind of greediness of that mi6 meets the
criminal world oh it looks so [ __ ]
sweet yeah I'm always happy to go back
to British crime for a little while
because like there's something and you
know like I know Guy Ritchie had a lot
to do with that but it's something like
specific about like a more British kind
of little--it and british espionage you
know and james mcavoy looks like he's
having a great time i mean this is
exactly the same character from split it
looks like you got to chill out after
Swift is like our class I'm just gonna
be your sidekick and be cool the degrees
really doing action in this trailer but
he still looks like a badass and I got
John Goodman's becoming information yeah
yeah yeah guy shows up with a little bit
of gravitas and a whole lot of is
plotted yeah simple plot you know she's
mission someone's killing the operatives
she's got to find out who's doing it
along the way she's gonna get have sex
and kill people you know this is one of
those trailers everything looks cool and
now all I can do is hope that the movie
is just as cool as the operation she on
awake return bisexual I would love that
too the action movies lesbian sex scene
is always badass and cool and sexy to
get and we haven't done that with two
guys yet yeah
Taye Diggs yet bring a mint or Taye
Diggs in common after a common would be
down dude that see with the umbrellas
there's this channel called I think
improv city where they set up a bunch of
people to like this audio or they all
have to do a specific improvised thing
at the same time but it's like a large
public place there's a lot of people and
like everyone freeze and but there's
like a lot of people around who are not
in on it so like what happened what the
Rovers okay I got it like a weird combo
flash mob mannequin challenge in a way
yeah so that's so this umbrella portion
reminder become one of them watching it
it's under cool set these two this looks
like it has all the like the one of the
whichever of the two John wick guys is
responsible for like all the neon lights
and like the crazy symmetry shots like
stuff like that in the first John wick I
feel as with it here yeah yeah I really
like the way the trailer mixed the songs
oh yeah that mashup of uh what is that
black skinhead and personal Jesus yeah I
was cool pretty sick and also you know
but even before that Joe is that new
order Joy Division I was with the first
song Joy Division I think ashamed lot in
the first 20 seconds of this trailer at
one point I know is she a real blonde
whatever character that's the backstory
she followed into a pit of atomic acid
and she comes out with this bleach Joe I
love it acid can't fix a girl a lot hey
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects yeah
John's reads to Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
house and the real rejects
click that notification bell shout out
to yo Keanu Reeves
and Charlie Theron once did work
together in a movie called sweet
November I remember that and I rented it
I don't I didn't watch it oh yeah it's
not the group it's not a great hey well
maybe they'll finally get back together
and sweet November 2 on November 2 kill
[Laughter]